Democrats formulate their 20/20
narrative the Omar Talib BDS train
continues to roll and antiva gets more
favorable media coverage I'm Ben Shapiro
this is the Ben Shapiro show all righty
well we have a lot to get to today we'll
get to the mt4 hubbub in Portland a
little bit later on in the show plus
we'll get to the economic update but we
begin today with the Democrats trotting
out the new narrative for 2020 it was
obvious that this was going to be the
narrative for 2020 the truth is it was
the narrative for 2012 it just wasn't
the narrative for 2016 so in 2012 the
Democrats ran on the platform that
effectively speaking there was no great
way for the for the United States to get
past its racial bias except by electing
Barack Obama president of the United
States again that was the only good way
to do this and Mitt Romney thus had to
be thrown under the bus Mitt Romney was
a terrible no good very bad man Mitt
Romney was the kind of fellow who was
going to put people back in Chains in
the words of Joe Biden well then in 2016
the Democrats which stood up because
Hillary Clinton was the nominee and it
turns out it's difficult to run on a
narrative of American racism well your
nominee is a white woman and so now we
are moving forward to 2020 Donald Trump
has been the president by that point for
four years and people are looking for a
narrative to use against from now there
are many narratives that the Democrats
could use against Trump in 2020 they
could do what Joe Biden has done they
could use a character narrative that
Donald Trump is short on character the
Donald Trump is divisive and derisive
the Donald Trump is mean and cruel and
alienate suburban women that would be
their smart move the reason it would be
their smart move is because it would
attempt to emulate the coalition of 2008
for Barack Obama so in 2008 Barack Obama
did not run on the race narrative in
2008 Barack Obama did not run on the
idea that the United States was deeply
riffed by racial strife and that the
only way to fix that was to elect him
president he basically ran on the
suggestion that America was moving
toward a better day no red states no
blue states the United States he ran on
hope and change and then he won a
broad-based victory yes with heavy black
turnout but also with extraordinarily
high white turnout and with a lot of
people in the middle switching sides to
favor him he won a much broader victory
in 2008 than he did in 2012 then in 2012
Obama created what Democrats thought was
the new electoral normal and the new
electoral normal suggested that he was
going to be at the demo
rats forever we're going to be able to
turn out at insane rates minority voters
they were going to be able to turn out
at wildly disproportionate rates
minority voters that's why Barack Obama
was reelected because he turned out
minority voters and heavy numbers and a
lot of swing states like Ohio for
example or about 10% of the population
was black but about 13% of the
electorate was black so Democrats in
2016 thought okay the new normal is 2012
not 2008 and they thought that Hillary
Clinton was going to be able to draw
exactly those same black voters and they
would show up at exactly the same rates
and then she would run away with the
election it didn't happen well now move
forward to 2020 and Democrats have to
make a choice do they choose to run I'm
Barack Obama circa 2008 or do they
choose to run I'm Barack Obama circa
2012 and it is becoming more and more
obvious that Democrats are addicted to
the narrative that 2012 is the new
coalition not 2008 that running on the
basis of trumps moral shortcomings and
lack of character is not a winning
strategy instead the strategy is going
to be that Donald Trump is a vicious
racist that America is terribly horribly
sinful and racist and races racism has
built into its DNA and the only way to
fix that is to elect a Democrat now
that's gonna be very awkward if Joe
Biden is the nominee if Joe Biden is the
nominee it's gonna be extraordinarily
awkward for Democrats to run on the race
narrative because Joe Biden's own racial
history is as we have seen from Kamala
Harris's critiques of him at least
somewhat checkered going all the way
back to the 1970s and desegregation
through busing and all of this but if
they were to nominate somebody like Cory
Booker or Camille Harris it becomes a
lot simpler in any case the media who
are well educated white liberals who
live in major metropolitan areas it
turns out that they are more interested
in the racial narrative than they are in
the reach out to the white folks in the
middle of the country narrative they're
more interested in replicating the 2012
Obama coalition than they are in
replicating the 2008 Obama coalition and
this mirrors some of the statistics that
we have seen about the political
preferences of white upper educated
college liberals living in major cities
that those are the people who are the
foundation of the new woke politics and
it is more important to appeal to those
people than it is to appeal to the
people in the middle of the country
according to Democrats because those are
the people who constitute the media and
so you're seeing the Democratic Party in
breaks they're 2020 strategy there maybe
2020 strategy at
turns out is not only the Donald Trump
is racist but that Donald Trump is
representative of a long line of
American racism stretching all the way
back to slavery and that America is rife
with endemic problems that are created
by slavery and that cannot be wiped out
absent total revolution that is the
narrative that Democrats are trying to
draw it justifies the revolutionary
rhetoric it justifies their radicalism
it justifies nearly everything if it
turns out that America was based in
rooted in not just that America was
reliant upon economically but that
America was all of its institutions were
infected with and infused with and
rooted in and based on slavery than the
only way to fix those institutions is to
rip them down to branch and branch and
tree I mean that the entire thing must
be ripped out and that is what Democrats
are now claiming as we will see that
Democrats particularly again those media
those media radicals this is the
narrative they are pushing we'll get to
that in just one second I'll explain
what the narrative is and why it is
taking a grain of truth and then blowing
it up into a massive massive lie again
slavery is a massive part of America's
Founding it is not the root of America's
Founding we'll get to that in just one
second first let's talk about how you
staff your business so let's say that
you did let's say a podcast for example
and let's say it was somebody's job
during that podcast to make sure that
the microphone that was normally
attached to your shirt actually was
attached to your shirt and that didn't
happen well then you might think to
yourself hey I need a new employee and
that's when you look to zipper quarter
zip recruiter com zip recruiter sends
your job posting to over 100 of the
web's leading job boards but they don't
stop there as applications come in zip
recruiter analyzes each one and then
spotlights the top candidates so you
never miss a great match the zipper
career is so effective that four out of
five employers who post on zip recruiter
got a quality candidate through the site
within the very first day right now my
listeners can try zip recruiter for free
at this exclusive web address zip
recruit com slash daily wire that's zip
recruiter com slash Dai ly WI re zip
recruiter com slash daily wire zip
recruiter is indeed the smartest way to
hire and if you don't intend on firing
up reduce you just want to add another
producer whose sole job it is to make
sure that microphone is added to your
shirt then you should check out zip
recruiter comm slash daily wear make
sure that your employees are the best
and
sure that they live on tenterhooks every
time you read an ad zip recruiter comm
slash daily wired go check them out
right now okay so as I say the
Democratic narrative leading up to 2020
has is now being formulated and it's
being formulated in real time it's being
backfilled and it's being backfilled
because it turns out that the democratic
narrative was supposed to be Donald
Trump is a Russian tool and it's no
longer Donald Trump is a Russian tool
now it is America is rife with racism
Donald Trump is representative of the
James Buchanan South that Donald Trump
is representative of of Jhansi Calhoun
right that's that that is who Trump is
that's what America is and this is now
the narrative that is being pushed by
the left now as I say as we will see
there is a there is more than a grain of
truth to the idea that slavery was a
deeply rooted endemic part of American
life for several hundred years by
beginning in 1619 and ending officially
in 1863 right yes that it official it
depends on whether you're dating it from
the Emancipation Proclamation or the
fourteenth amendment might have say 1865
in any case the the fact is slavery was
of course a massive part of America's
history Jim Crow was a massive part of
America's history but it is a lie to
suggest that America was founded based
on slavery surely the Puritans who
arrived on the Mayflower were not there
to bring slavery about nor was it the
southern economy that lent the great
strength of America's economy her
strength we'll get to that in just one
se but here's the thing
bata O'Rourke who is now trying to
channel exactly what the media want from
him so beta O'Rourke as a man in search
of love bata auric had that love back in
the 2018 Senate race against Ted Cruz he
had it going right it was it was gonna
be his moment and the media loved him
for it well now beta O'Rourke is a man
in search of love he is searching for
media love and the only way he can see
toward finding it is becoming the most
white woke person on planet Earth
so yesterday bado announces his campaign
his campaign is that America was founded
on racism and so we need a woke white
guy who was born into immense privilege
he's what about nine million dollars
because his daddy was very very wealthy
and very very powerful in his area we
need that guy to lead us to a broader
American future in this country though
we would like to thank otherwise was
founded
on racism has persisted through racism
and is racist today but this racism
though foundational for so long it had
flown under the surface but it was only
until this administration and this
president that that racism was invited
out into the open Trump is the real
America according to beta our work right
Trump is representative of America's
true dark evil slave ridden heart now
you may be saying to yourself I've never
held a slave I am NOT a racist and
you're right you've never held a slave
you're not a racist but according to the
Democrats even if you are not a racist
you still suffer from the after pangs of
white supremacy it is buried deep within
you it is unconscious it's exactly as
aoc said a couple of weeks ago in a
tweet thread white supremacy is so
deeply embedded in American life that
there is no way of extra cating it from
American life which suggests that the
only solution is radical chemotherapy
but if the cancer is everywhere if it's
infected the entire body politic the
only answer is radical chemotherapy and
that's what bado is calling for this
justifies the radical changes Democrats
are calling for it justifies the
overthrow of a lot of the wonderful
great things about America because after
all if all those wonderful great things
are rooted in one of the most evil
institutions in the history of mankind
it's difficult to make the moral case
for them being retained even if they
have had some good positive effects as
we will see this is exactly what the New
York Times is about to claims and the
New York Times has launched something
called the 16:19 project now on its face
there is nothing wrong with the 16:19
project there's nothing not only is
there nothing wrong there's something
quite good about America learning about
its own history about staring the evils
of racism in the face about staring the
evils of slavery and white supremacism
and Jim Crow directly in the face
recognizing their ugliness too many
Americans don't know much about slavery
used here it is a word and they don't
understand the tremendous suffering
they've never read any of the slave
memoirs they've never read Frederick
Douglass they've never they've never
watched any of the documentaries about
slavery they haven't looked at any of
the materials they don't understand the
deep cruelty the a malignant malice and
racism an evil of slavery many Americans
don't understand how that was projected
for 100 years through Jim Crow how
institution
took the took slavery as their model and
then use that in order to keep black
people down and segregate them and
destroy their lives and make it
impossible for them to progress in
American society too many black folks in
the United States right there that is
stuff that of course should be taught
about and if the 16:19 project were that
that would be one thing but the 16:19
project is not that as it turns out the
16:19 project is about something that is
much deeper and much more radical and
that is radically rethinking America as
the quote-unquote product of slavery
that everything in America is due to
slavery that America's founding ideology
is a slave ideology it's an ideology
about promoting and promulgating slavery
and so as we'll see the New York Times
says has shifted its premise now the
reason the New York Times is doing this
is purely political this is not because
they've suddenly become interested in
educating the American people about
slavery 150 years after it ended that is
not what is going on here this is a
political move by the New York Times and
they're basically admitting as much
we'll get to that in just one second
first I look at screens all day long
right whether I'm looking at the cameras
but I'm looking at these this screen
right here in front of me whether I'm
looking at my phone I'm looking at
screens all day long I can give you a
real headache hey and then when I go
home I'm watching TV with my wife
sometimes more screens probably out of
every 15 hours a day that I am awake
probably seven or eight of them I'm
staring at some form of screen I'm not
unusual that way most Americans are
doing the same thing well maybe that's
giving you eye trouble maybe it's making
your vision worse well this is one of
the reasons why you need Felix gray blue
light filtering glasses you need to
protect your eyes from the effects of
the screen because you're not gonna stop
looking at the screens nor should you I
mean you have to work the majority of
Americans live a tired dry eyes blurry
vision headaches caused by screens if
this sounds familiar
Felix gray glasses are for you Felix
gray glasses filter out 90% of
high-energy blue light and eliminate 99%
of glare coming from your daily barrage
of screens
unlike other blue light filtering
glasses Felix gray uses proprietary blue
light technology embedded into the lens
as opposed to a cheap coating that can
chip or scratch over time Felix Gray's
glasses they're fashionable high-quality
blue light protection widely accessible
by offering a variety of frames for all
face shapes and style preferences I've
got these Felix wear glasses I wear them
around the office believe it or not it
makes me look awesome that look like an
MSNBC host just as cool but actually
they're really good-looking
Felix great glasses are available in non
prescription prescription
readers as well as adult and kid sizes
don't go another day looking at screens
without the help of some Felix Grey's go
to Felix grey glasses dot-com / Ben for
free shipping and 30 days of risk-free
returns or exchanges that's Felix gray
glasses comm slash man they look
terrific and again they will protect
your eyes which is the most important
thing Felix gray glasses comm slash Ben
go check them out right now okay so as I
say this is part of a of a narrative
that is now being driven by the media
and that narrative is again rooted in a
basic truth which is that slavery was a
serious part of America's Founding that
it was a a massive part of America's
history which again I think most people
know on a basic level but don't
understand it a root emotional level all
of that would be fine and dandy but that
is not what the 16:19 project really is
about the 16:19 project is really about
driving a narrative ahead of 2020 the
Washington Examiner reported last week
that Dean Baquet the executive editor of
the New York Times said recently that
after the Mulla report the paper has to
shift the focus of its coverage from the
Trump Russia affair to the president's
alleged racism but ket said that they
had built up their entire staff
basically to cover Trump Russia and then
it turns out that Muller blew up that
narrative and but cat said I think we've
got to change the x must quote write
more deeply about the country race and
other divisions I mean the vision for
coverage for the next two years is what
I talked about earlier said back at how
do we cover a guy who makes these kind
of remarks how do we cover the world's
reaction to him how do we do that while
continuing to cover his policies how do
we cover America that's become so
divided by Donald Trump and that in and
of itself is an editorial decision that
it's Trump dividing America as opposed
to pre-existing divisions that have been
exacerbated and made worse by President
Trump and then he continues he vows a
vision for the paper for the next two
years quote how do we grapple with all
the stuff you're talking about how do we
write about race in a thoughtful way
something we haven't done in a large way
in a long time that to me is the vision
for coverage you all are going to have
to help us shape that vision but I think
that's what we're gonna have to do for
the rest of the next two years and in
case you think that that is the
Washington Examiner taking this stuff
out of context it is not there's a full
transcript of Dean Baquet exchange
he's the executive editor of the New
York Times his exchange with a bunch of
staffers that was obtained by slate and
in the middle of this exchange he
references the 16:19 project
three separate times and here is what he
said okay I'll give you each of the
context he says quote what I'm saying is
that our readers and some of our staff
cheer us when we take on Donald Trump
but they juror us when we take on Joe
Biden they sometimes want us to pretend
he was not elected president but he was
elected president and our job is to
figure out why and how and to hold the
administration to account if you're
independent that's what you do the same
newspaper that this week will publish
the 16:19 project the most ambitious
examination of the legacy of slavery
ever undertaken in a newspaper to try
and understand the forces that led to
the election of Donald Trump in other
words slavery led to the election of
Donald Trump and the 16:19 project is an
attempt to explain that and that is what
he's saying he just heard me quote him
and that of course is not the only time
that Dean Baquet talks about the 16:19
project a staffer asked him about the
16:19 project and said this quote hello
I have another question about racism I'm
wondering to what extent you think that
the fact of racism and white supremacy
being sort of the foundation of this
country should play into our reporting
just because it feels to me like it
should be a starting point you know let
these conversations about what is racist
what isn't racist I just feel like
racism is in everything this is what a
staffer says to the executive editor of
the New York Times in everything yeah it
should be considered in our science
reporting in our culture reporting in
our national reporting and so to me it's
less about the individual instances of
racism and sort of how we're thinking
about racism and white supremacy as the
foundation of all the systems in the
country all that's in the foundation not
just a part of all the systems in the
country the foundation of all the
systems in the country not just that
racism was something that America has
fought with and struggled with and given
into and fought to overcome but the root
of all of our institutions is what this
staffer is saying which is sort of like
saying that let's say that you get
married and let's say that your marriage
involves emotional abuse that the
marriage was rooted on emotional abuse
no the marriage was probably rooted on
all of the other stuff and then endured
it despite the emotional abuse emotional
abuse is a major part of the story but
it is not in fact the whole story nor it
is the foundation of the story the
staffer says I think particularly as we
are launching a 16:19 project I feel
like it's going to open
- even more criticism from people who
are like okay while you're saying this
and you're producing this big project
about this but are you guys actually
considering this in your daily reporting
the staffer said it's less about the
individual instances of racism and sort
of how we're thinking about racism and
white supremacy as the foundation of all
the systems in the country all of them
and here's how the cap responded quote I
do think that race and understanding of
race should be a part of how we cover
the American story
sometimes news organizations sort of
forget that in the moment but of course
it should be I mean one reason we all
signed off on the 16:19 project and made
it so ambitious and expansive was to
teach our readers to think a little bit
more like that so they're gonna teach
their readers that they have to think of
every issue in America through the lens
of race race in the next year and I
think this is to be frank what I would
hope you come away with this discussion
with race in the next year is going to
be a huge part of the American story
question why in the next year what's
happening in the next year anybody you
let the election obviously race is only
a part of the American story for the
next year how weird how weird the
timeline matches up precisely with the
2020 election he says I mean race in
terms not only of african-americans in
their relationship with Donald Trump but
Latinos and immigration I think one of
the things I would love to come out of
this with is for people to feel very
comfortable coming to me and saying
here's how I would like you to consider
telling that story because the reason
you have a diverse newsroom to be frank
so that you can have people pull
together to try to tell that story at a
verse newsroom he doesn't mean
ideologically diverse newsroom or
philosophically diverse a newsroom he
means a racially diverse newsroom of
course that is the only thing that
matters in the end for Dean Baquet so
the point that I am making is again not
that it is bad to review the history of
slavery in the United States or to try
in some statistical data driven way
examine the impact of slavery on a
going-forward basis in American life and
how we obliterate the vestiges of Jim
Crow and slavery in our institutions
when we identify them I'm all for all of
those things those are all great things
that is not what this project is this
project is a media driven and enterprise
designed to suggest that people who
support Donald Trump are part of the
legacy of slavery that those who oppose
Donald Trump are not it is a it is a bit
of virtue signaling on the part of the
New York Times not designed to raise
awareness about America's past but
designed to do so specifically in order
to draw
modern connections with political
movements they don't like how do I know
this because that's exactly what they do
in one second I'm going to explain to
you some of the pieces from the 1619
project there they're a bevy of them the
vast majority of them are not very good
there are a couple that I think are
appropriate I think that there's one in
particular that I think is appropriate
if overstated and then there are a bunch
that are really not that are really
quite sloppy that are designed to be
op-eds directed against conservatives
and the idea here is that if you say
that these op-eds are sloppy and
directed against conservatives it's
because you're not taking the legacy of
white supremacy and sit and slavery
seriously enough this is designed
specifically not to bring America
together to learn about our history but
to polarize around modern political
issues by linking them directly with
slavery by saying if you disagree with
me it's because you don't take slavery
seriously it's because you don't take
white supremacy seriously and if you did
you would recognize that I'm right on my
politics today that is what these pieces
are which is why they are universally
written by members of the political left
now there are people on the right or
historians who have studied slavery
theoretically some of them could have
been asked to write there are prominent
black people in America who are
conservative senator Tim Scott would be
a good example of this Jason Reilly at
The Wall Street Journal there are plenty
of them Thomas so none of them were
asked to write a piece for any of this
instead it was a bunch of left-leaning
scholars and commentators I hesitate to
call Jamelle Bouie as scholars I don't
think that he is a specialist I'm not a
scholar either by the way on this stuff
and yet what you see too much is the is
the New York Times basically driving a
narrative that's what this is in a
second we'll get to all of that first
let's talk about the fact that you've
been encouraged for far too long to buy
now and pay for it later this is how
people get roped in to credit card debt
get that credit card take out the credit
card we'll give you 15% off on this
purchase then you take out the credit
card you spend too much you can't pay it
off then you're getting charged like 25
percent a month on interest rates
suddenly you're really behind the
eight-ball well this is where you need
Lending Club Lending Club can
consolidate your debt and pay off your
credit cards with one fixed monthly
payment Lending Club has helped millions
of people regain control of their
finances with affordable fixed-rate
personal loans no trips to a bank no
high interest credit cards just go to
Lending Club com tell them about
yourself how much you want to borrow
pick the terms that are right for you if
you're approved your loan is
automatically deposited into your bank
count in as little as a few days Lending
Club is the number one peer-to-peer
lending platform with over 35 billion
dollars in loans issued it's really easy
to get into debt but it shouldn't be
that hard to get out of it this is why
you need Lending Club at least you need
a plan to get out and Lending Club can
help you go to Lending Club comm / Ben
check your rate in minutes borrow up to
40 grand
that's Lending Club comm / Ben Lending
Club comm / Ben all loans made by web
bank member FDIC Equal Housing lender
that's Lending Club com / Ben go check
them out right now okay so now to the
contents of the 1619 project it's this
big issue of the new york times magazine
and it leads off this way in August of
1619 a ship appeared on this horizon
near Point Comfort a coastal port in the
British colony of Virginia it carried
more than 20 enslaved Africans who were
sold to the colonists no aspect of the
country that would be formed here has
been untouched by the years of slavery
that followed now I think that's an
overstatement but a mild one meaning
that of course America was affected
deeply and in a variety of ways by
slavery I think it would be difficult to
say that no aspect of the country was
untouched by years of slavery but that's
within the realm of possibility they say
I'm the 400th anniversary of this
fateful moment it is finally time to
tell our story truthfully hey and then
the the original text suggested they've
changed the text a little bit they said
that the true founding of the country
was at 1619 we have to understand 1619
as the true founding this re here they
didn't change it here's what it says the
1619 project is a major initiative from
the New York Times observing the 400th
anniversary of the beginning of American
slavery which again worth while it aims
to reframe the country's history this is
where we get into trouble it aims to
reframe the country's history
understanding 1619 as our true founding
and placing the consequences of slavery
and the contributions of black Americans
at the very center of the story we tell
ourselves about who we are and now again
placing the consequences of slavery and
the contributions of black Americans at
the center of the American story is
totally fine you know I don't have a
problem with that but 1619 was not the
true founding of the country it was not
1607 was Jamestown Plymouth Rock was
1619 it was in a different part of the
country hey this is this this notion
slavery was not just a part of the
American Founding but the central factor
in the American Founding is just a
historical lie it is not true it is
historically inaccurate it is inept it
ignores the fact that there was an
entire northern part of the country in
which slavery was banned it ignores the
Civil War it ignores 200 years of
attempted development to wave from
slavery it ignores a lot and as we will
see the essays that are attached to the
1619 project are not about the legacy of
slavery so much as they are about an
attempt to link modern politics with
slavery
so that Democrats and liberals and
leftists can claim that any conservative
policy is in fact rooted in slavery and
thus racist and bigoted so there are
there a couple pieces here that are
worthwhile there's one by Nicole Hannah
Jones that I think is is over over
stated but generally correct which is
our democracy's founding ideals were
false when they were written black
Americans have fought to make them true
now that little stinger right there is
not true hey they were not false when
they were written they were wrongly
applied when they were written if you
read the Declaration of Independence or
the Constitution both of which Frederick
Douglass suggested were freedom
documents and he was right the founding
ideals were not false when they were
written they were wrongly applied only
to white Americans they were not applied
to Africans and that of course was wrong
but they were not false when written hey
now maybe we can read it that they were
falsely applied when written but if the
idea is that the ideals were originally
corrupt that's not true this particular
piece is actually fairly good right this
piece as I say by Nicole Hannah Jones
talks about how black Americans have
shaped America changed America made
America better helped America live up to
its original eternal values and that is
that's good right that's worthwhile so
this piece well I say I think that this
piece overstates the case in terms of
the impact of slavery on the nation I
think that in general this piece is fine
and worthwhile right she says it would
be historically inaccurate to reduce the
contributions of black people so the
vast material wealth created by our
bondage black Americans have also been
and continue to be foundational to the
idea of American freedom of course
totally agree more than any group in
this country's history
we have served generation after
generation
an overlooked but vital role it is we
who have been perfectors of this
democracy that is that is true although
I think that you would have to include
among the people who have perfected the
democracy all the people who fought to
free slaves including hundreds of
thousands of white people who died to
free slaves including the abolitionist
movement which was generally led by
white people in other words it was not
just black people fighting against white
people it was good people fighting
against people who were wrong and to
boiled that down to black purple versus
white people is is racially untrue it is
true that black people were fighting for
rights that they ought to have had it is
also true that they were joined in that
fight by a huge number of people who did
not share their race but did share their
ideals that is what made America great
the this Nicole Hannah Jones rights the
United States is a nation founded on
both an ideal and a lie our Declaration
of Independence approved on July 4th
1776 proclaims that all men are created
equal and endowed by their creator with
certain unalienable rights but the white
man who drafted those words did not
believe them to be true for the hundreds
of thousands of black people in our
midst ok that's not true for all the
white men and that's it's just not true
but for all the weight men it's true for
some of the slaveholding white men it
was certainly on not true for a bunch of
the founders who are actual
abolitionists who opposed slavery John
Adams opposed slavery of course despite
being violently denied the freedom and
justice promised to all black Americans
believed fervently in the American creed
through centuries of black resistance in
protests we have helped the country live
up to its founding ideals again all of
this is fine all of this is good
ok this particular essay is not the
problem it's the other essays that heard
of the problem is there a bunch of other
essays these other essays linked
everything from capitalism to Trump to
the criminal justice system to
differences in medical outcome to
slavery so in other words anything that
the left doesn't like any inequality is
due to inequity and any policy the left
is not like is due to slavery there's an
essay in the New York Times magazine as
part of the 1619 project that suggests
that America's failure to embrace
Medicare for all is rooted in slavery
then America's failure to embrace
nationalized health care is rooted in
slavery now that's just idiocy I'm sorry
that that has nothing to do with history
and as I mean I've read all these pieces
if
pieces have a common pattern and it's
very sloppy it's very sloppy thinking
and it's very sloppy writing first the
pieces open with talking about the
depredations of slavery again totally
valid and worthwhile we should all
understand that we should all know that
we should all learn the history got it
worth it good then they all fast forward
about a hundred and fifty years and then
they say and just as slavery was bad
then here is an institution now I don't
like and it's connected to slavery and
they don't really explain how that
institution is deeply connected with
slavery they just sort of fast-forward
and then make the assumption and they
assume that the good-hearted liberal
readers at the New York Times will
understand precisely what they're
talking about because of the
good-hearted liberal readers at the New
York Times wish to believe that their
political opponents are pro-slavery and
Pro Jim Crow it's extraordinarily lazy
as extraordinarily lazy writing by a bet
by the New York Times editors by the
columnist for the most part and and it's
it's it is intellectually it is
intellectually sluggish it is it is just
not tightly written if you're gonna make
an argument like every institution in
America is founded on slavery that
should be some pretty tightly reasoned
stuff because that's counterintuitive it
turns out that the north industrial
power was significantly greater than the
South's agricultural power and you have
an essay in the New York Times
suggesting that American capitalism is
rooted in slavery that's nonsense it's
just crap the reason the South lost is
because their enterprise was not free
market or capitalistic capitalism is not
rooted in the destruction of other
people's human rights that is violation
of free markets because chief among the
priorities of a free market is the
ability to alienate your own labor
you can't enslave people in a free
market if you live by free market
systems ok I'll get to this consensus
realize at the root of the free market
system we'll get some more of this in
just one second again this is the New
York Times driving a narrative it is not
them exploring history and I my great
fear is that the New York Times is
purposefully doing this sort of stuff
deliberately and cynically in order to
suggest that if you disagree with the
implications that they are drawing from
slavery that you are not taking slavery
seriously and that's a why you can take
slavery and Jim Crow seriously can take
racism seriously and still disagree with
the New York Times and medicare-for-all
is not mandated by opposition to slavery
for God's sake I'll get to that in just
one second first got some great news The
Daily wire
somehow managed to turn four years old
unbelievably as a thank you to our fans
we are giving away one month of our
premium monthly subscription to anyone
who uses the code birthday that's
correct for all of August as we
celebrate this milestone we are giving
away a free first month for our new
premium monthly subscribers again just
use that code birthday come join the fun
never been a better time to become a
member we are in the homestretch also
when it comes to our backstage show
there are only a few days left to
purchase tickets to our backstage live
show it's a special one-night only event
this Wednesday August 21st at the
fantastic Terrace Theatre in Long Beach
California I'll be there daily where
god-king Jeremy Boren will be there
Andrew Clavin will be there Michael
moles will be there live we'll get into
politics pop culture will answer your
questions from the audience
tickets are available at daily wire.com
slash backstage including our limited
VIP packages that guarantee premium
seating photos meet and greets with each
of us a gift from me I promise you it's
beautiful and more they're selling fast
so head on over to daily wire.com slash
backstage get yours today we're
basically out of ticket so if you want
to buy buy today daily we're calm slash
backstage go check us out right now
please we have said subscribe and there
are folks on the Left who literally
spend all day just trying to parse what
we say so that they can target us for
destruction the way you prevent that is
by going over to daily wire and
subscribing right now and becoming part
of the team that protects us from the
cruelties of a left that seeks to
destroy everyone with whom they disagree
in the most cynical and nasty of ways go
check us out a daily where we really
appreciate it we're the largest
fastest-growing conservative podcast and
radio show in the nation
[Music]
you
okay so as I say the 16:19 project
contains a couple of essays that are
good and some poetry that's good and
then it contains a lot of cynical
politicking by people who are cynical
politico's take an example there's a
piece by Jamelle Bouie now Jamelle Bouie
is a very radical dude on politics and
he still claims that stacey abrams is
governor of georgia he still thinks that
she lost the vote by fifty thousand
votes he still thinks that she was the
duly elected governor of Georgia and
only racism prevented that despite the
fact that black voters turned out in
massive numbers in the last election
cycle and were not in fact suppressed he
has a piece in the New York Times
Magazine in the 16:19 project and says
America holds on to an undemocratic
assumption from its founding that some
people deserve more power than others
and now you can tell from that blurb
that this is going to be wildly over
broad that he's now going to suggest
that because America was founded with
slavery as part of its founding compact
that slavery was tolerated and there was
an assumption that some people deserve
power and others did not that this is
now the same in American politics so he
talks about the Tea Party and he talks
about the debt limit standoff that took
place in 2011 he says quote the debt
limit standoff was a case study of a
fundamental change within the Republican
Party after Obama took office in 2009
Republicans would either win total
victory or they would wreck the system
itself the Senate Republican leader
Mitch McConnell used a variety of
procedural tactics to effectively
nullify the president's ability to
nominate federal judges and fill
vacancies in the executive branch in the
minority he used the filibuster to an
unprecedented degree
well actually harry reid then ended the
judicial filibuster that was
unprecedented in the majority after
republicans won the senate in the 2010
midterm elections he led an
extraordinary blockade of the Supreme
Court stopping the Senate from even
considering the president's nominee for
the bench hey first of all the
Republicans didn't win the Senate in
2010 they won the Senate in 2014 the
Democrats between 2010 and 2014 ensured
that the judicial filibuster went away
harry reid did it at the time so you at
least got to get your facts straight
hey the Republicans won back to Congress
in 2010 in any case the debt limit he's
trying to suggest that the debt limit
standoff believe it or not is racism and
slavery equivalent that it is an
outgrowth of it this is where did this
destructive sectarian style of partisan
politics come from
conventional wisdom traces its roots the
Gingrich revolution of the 1990s whose
architect pioneered a hardball insurgent
style of political combat undermining
norms and dismantling congressional
institutions for the sake of power this
is true enough but the Republican Party
of the Obama years didn't just recycle
its Gingrich era accesses it also
pursued a policy of total opposition not
just blocking Obama but also casting him
as fundamentally illegitimate and
unamerican he may have been elected by a
majority of the voting public but that
majority didn't count it didn't
represent the real America and Ezra's
bunch of crap sorry it's just bunch of
crap
Republicans impeached impeached Bill
Clinton in the 1990s they never made a
move to impeach Barack Obama despite the
myriad scandals that cropped up during
his administration I'm not aware of a
single major Republican figure who said
that Barack Obama was not the legitimate
President of the United States despite
the fact that Democrats have claimed
that George W Bush was illegitimate
they've claimed that Donald Trump is
illegitimate so this is just not true
and doubts about Barack Obama's belief
system came from Barack Obama being an
extraordinarily radical figure Barack
Obama said he wanted to fundamentally
transform the nature of the country
that's a pretty radical statement
Jamelle Bouie says Obama's election
reignited a fight about democratic
legitimacy about who can claim the
country as their own and who has the
right to act as a citizen that is as old
as American democracy itself what a
bunch of hooey really what a bunch of
hooey did anyone like who was claiming
the Barack Obama did not have the right
to act as a citizen and the reactionary
position in this conflict has buoy which
seems to narrow the scope of
participation and arrest the power of
majorities beyond the limits of the
Constitution has its own peculiar
history not just in the ideological
battles of the founding but in the other
institutions that defined the American
Republic as much as any other okay so
basically if you opposed Obama it's
because you were an outgrowth of slavery
and then he goes into the history of
Jhansi Calhoun right an actual
secessionist who was who was militantly
in favor of slavery and talked about it
being a positive good for black people
vicious racist John C Calhoun he says
listen to how he fast-forwards here hey
ready listen to this fast-forwarding and
this is I say intellectually
intellectually incredibly sloppy
incredibly lazy
sloppy intellectually he says Calhoun
died in 1850 ten years later following
the idea of nullification to its
conclusion the South seceded from the
Union after Abraham Lincoln won the
White House without a single southern
state war came a few months later and
four years of fighting destroyed the
system of slavery Calhoun fought to
protect but parts of his legacy survived
his deep suspicions of maturity Arian
democracy
his view that government must protect
interests defined by their unique
geographic and economic characteristics
more than people would inform the
sectional politics of the South in the
20th century or solid blocks of southern
lawmakers worked collectively to stifle
any attempt to regulate the region okay
a couple of things here one suspicion of
majoritarian democracy is not unique to
John C Calhoun okay that is true for
everyone from Montesquieu to John Locke
it is true for all of the Enlightenment
philosophers who are the fans eight who
lay at the foundation of American
democracy if you read the Federalist
Papers there was deep concern about
majoritarian democracy which is why we
have checks and balances so this is not
unique to John C Calhoun Calhoun used it
in the worst possible way and for the
worst possible excuse but to blame a
belief in federalism on favoring slavery
is just historically illiterate Bowie
says despite insurgencies at home the
populist party for example swept through
Georgia and North Carolina in the 1890s
reactionary white leaders were able to
maintain an iron grip on federal offices
until the Voting Rights Act of state of
1965 when another thing worth noting
here when he says majoritarianism ought
to rule the day populism ought to rule
the day you know is a majoritarian
populist president like probably our
first one maybe our second after Teddy
Roosevelt Woodrow Wilson a a brutal
horrible racist who declared himself a
big man governing with the will of the
people through majority without
reference to the checks and balances of
American government those checks and
balances were designed to protect in
many cases what what one justice in the
supreme court called a case called
Caroline products it discrete and
insular minority in other words black
people have largely been a discrete and
insular minority throughout American
history the system should have been
designed to protect those discrete and
insular minorities not just majorities
majoritarianism for most of American
history was the worst threat to black
people in the United States he says even
even then the last generation of
segregationist senators held on through
the 1960s into the early 2000s you know
like their predecessors by geography and
their stake in Jim Crow segregation they
were a powerful force in national
politics a block that vetoed anything
that touched their regional prerogatives
so now his fast forwarded all the way
from 1865 to the early 2000s and now
he's gonna claim that everything that
that he opposes is in is an outgrowth of
slavery he says there's a homegrown
ideology of reaction in the United
States enix crypto inextricably tied to
our system of slavery and while the
racial content of that ideology has
attenuated over time the basic framework
remains fear of rival political
majorities of demographic replacement of
a government that threatens privilege in
hierarchy so now if you oppose Bernie
Sanders you know a government that
threatens privilege and hierarchy then
that's because you've been you've been
somehow infused with the spirit of
slavery the past ten years of Republican
extremism is emblematic the tea party
billed itself as a reaction to debt and
spending but a close look shows it was
actually a reaction to an ascendant
majority of black people Latinos
asian-americans and liberal white people
and this is such self self praising
nonsense it must make you feel real good
to label all your political opponents
secret slavery advocates the larger
implication is clear says Jamelle Bouie
a majority made up of liberals and
people of color isn't a real majority no
it's a real majority but many of us have
concerns about a majority or
majoritarian system and those concerns
are embedded in the Constitution of the
United States for good reason majority
sometimes do horrible things to
minorities as Jamelle Bouie of all
people should understand anybody whose
minority in America should understand
the majorities they they're called
minorities for a reason majorities can
hurt minorities that's been a lot of the
history of the United States that's why
we should enshrine protections for
minorities why we should have checks and
balances for example the recent attempt
to place a citizenship question on the
census was an important part of this
effort to write people out of the polity
to use every available tool to weaken
their influence on American politics so
now Jamelle Bouie is trying to connect
the effort to determine whose illegal
immigrants in the country to slavery and
racism and then you wonder why why
conservatives are not taking in the
16:19 project at face value because um
you're the people who are writing it or
not
taking it seriously if you took
seriously talk about slavery you
wouldn't connect questions about
citizenship in the census with slavery
and it's an unserious thing to do and it
turns out a bunch of the pieces are like
this okay perhaps the silliest piece
comes courtesy of matthew desmond who's
written a book called eviction that's
actually a pretty interesting book but
he has a tendency to ascribe to American
capitalism all of the all of the
problems that individuals experience in
their lives he has a piece that cuts
against the very foundations of economic
theory for the last 200 years he has a
piece blaming capitalism on slavery so
I've already had Jamelle Bouie saying
that everything that he doesn't like in
today's politics is because of slavery
now we have matthew desmond writing a
piece that says in order to understand
the brutality of American capitalism you
have to start on the plantation weird
because I thought that if you wanted to
understand capitalism you might start
with you know Industrial Revolution the
Industrial Revolution in Britain maybe
you start with managerial capitalism in
the United States post-civil war maybe
you start with financial capitalism that
begins in the United States in the 1970s
and 80s to start with the most backward
part of the American economy you know
part of the American economy so backward
that the entire south was overrun simply
through the sheer industrial might of
the north it's pretty incredible but
matthew desmond somehow manages to turn
this ridiculous trick he connects martin
shkreli to slavery not kidding you so
here's again you want to make the
argument that slavery ought to be
examined as part of the legacy of
American institutions do it but this is
not the way to do it this is
irresponsible and it's cynical and it's
obviously politically motivated and by
the way it's just factually wrong in
many cases which means the political
motivations really matter more than they
otherwise would matthew desmond had the
species a couple of years before he was
convicted of securities fraud martin
shkreli
was the chief executive of a
pharmaceutical company that acquired the
rights to daraprim a life-saving
anti-parasitic drug and then he talked
about shkreli being terrible he says no
one wants to say it no one's proud of it
proud of it but this is a capitalist
society a capitalist system and
capitalist rules this is a capitalist
society it's a fatalistic mantra that
seems to get repeated to anyone who
questions why America can't be more fair
or equal but around the world there are
many types of capitalist societies
ranging from liberating to exploitative
protective to abusive democratic to
unregulated when Americans declare we
live in a capitalist society what
they're often defending is our nation's
peculiarly brutal economy know what I'm
defending when I say we live in a
capitalist society is that we live in an
economy that has generated the vast
majority of the world's growth for the
last 50 years and raised half of the
world's population from abject poverty
in the last 30 that's what I'm talking
about when I say we live in a capitalist
society but according to this columnist
for the 16:19 project matthew desmond
those searching for reasons the American
economy is uniquely severe and unbridled
have found answers in many places but
recently historians have pointed
persuasively to the nattie fields of
Georgia and Alabama - cotton houses in
slave auction blocks as the birthplace
of America's low road approach to
capitalism and then he talked about the
again this is the same sloppy
intellectual move we're gonna move
directly from slavery as bad -
capitalism is slavery which is a hell of
a move so he talks about nearly to
average American life times have passed
since the end of slavery only - it's not
surprising we can still feel the looming
presence of this institution which
helped turn a poor fledgling nation into
a financial Colossus the surprising bit
has to do with many of the eerily
specific ways slavery can still be felt
in our economic life oh really
you mean the agricultural economy that
represents what 3% of the American
economy nearly none of it based in
cotton and none of it rooted in slavery
right now that's that's the legacy of
like what are you talking about you I
mean industrial capitalism in the North
was rooted in slavery gonna have to
explain that one you're gonna have to
explain why financial capitalism is
rooted in slavery and as it turns out he
doesn't he just immediately jumps from
the evils of slavery and then fast
forward what where does it so what is
his connection his connection is that
slaveholders had a system of management
of their plantations and that the
systems of management were what adopted
by the the industrial north that's
absurd it's absurd on its face they were
not adopted by the industrial north that
would suggest that these plantations
were the site of incredible and
disproportionate productivity as opposed
to the north now they did become more
productive over time through these
managerial processes and mostly through
the use of machineries like the cotton
gin but the fact is that the industrial
north was
more powerful in the south and it was
not close slavery is a net drag on an
economy because to hire people it turns
out is cheaper than to have slaves that
people are motivated to work when they
are paid and not owned aside from all
the endemic moral evil of slavery as an
economic prospects Lavery is not good
for your economy nonetheless this
article argues that capitalism is rooted
in American slavery which is just silly
this is the uncompromising pursuit of
measurement and scientific accounting
displayed in slave plantations predates
industrialism northern factories would
not begin adopting these techniques
until decades after the Emancipation
Proclamation but supposedly it had to do
with slavery so you're telling me that
it started in the south but it was and
it was wonderful it worked amazing it
was wonderful economically but it wasn't
adopted for decades until that but it
was rooted in slavery he tries to
connect people using Excel to slavery I
am not kidding you he says companies
have developed software that records
workers keystrokes and mouse clicks
along with randomly capturing
screenshots multiple times a day the
core impulse behind that technology
pervaded plantations unbelievable
unbelievable
no literally unbelievable he says
consider a Wall Street financial
instrument as modern sounding as
collateralized debt obligation CDOs
those ticking time bombs back by
inflated home prices in the 2000s CDOs
were the grand shoulder of
mortgage-backed securities based on the
inflated value of enslaved people sold
in the 1820s and 1830s that's insane
that's insane you mean that
collateralized debt obligations like you
sell a mortgage that that's rooted in
slavery too because it turns out people
owned houses before that and took out
mortgages you're seriously connecting
the crash of 2007 to slavery the it's
just it's irresponsible and it's bad
journalism in fact it's not journalism
at all and as it turns out a lot of
these pieces are not a lot of these
pieces are designed to elicit a
particular emotional response that again
suggests that if you disagree with the
conclusion being from on you don't take
slavery seriously enough no I take
slavery incredibly seriously and Jim
Crow incredibly seriously as all
Americans should I should spend more
time getting educated you should spend
more time getting educated on it we all
should New York Times ain't doing that
New York Times is just saying if you
disagree with their political
conclusions it's because you
don't care enough about slavery and you
don't understand that at the heart of
every beating foundation of the United
States the beating heart of every
foundation of the United States lies
this evil institution and thus they all
must be torn down there's an article in
here by Brian Stevenson suggesting that
our criminal justice system is rooted in
slavery now again they're gonna have to
explain how it is that people commit
crimes and go to jail there are parts of
America's criminal justice system that
of course were vestiges of slavery and
brutality to black people in Jim Crow
particularly of course that's true but
the people in jail today and are not
there because of slavery or Jim Crow
it's because they committed a crime
right now it's cuz they committed a
crime and ten years ago and it's not
just prisons we also have articles that
suggest that if you oppose the
Affordable Care Act it's because you're
pro-slavery we have articles that
suggest that the complete that the gap
in maternal mortality between black
women and white women in the United
States is due to slavery and differences
in beliefs about racial racial
characteristics based on incredibly
flimsy evidence and also not really
explaining why it is that Europe has the
same gaps in Europe of course eliminated
slavery a lot earlier than the United
States so as I say this is a narrative
it's a narrative it's being driven and
the kick back against it should be on
that level it should not be on the level
of we shouldn't study this stuff and I
don't really see a lot of people or
making that case what I do see is a lot
of people on the Left who are cynically
suggesting that if you disagree with
them politically
it's because you don't take slavery
seriously enough and lead among them is
is Dean Baquet the executive editor of
the New York Times who's deliberately
attempting to link slavery with the 2020
election that's what's going on here
okay time for the thing I like and then
we'll get to a quick thing that I hate
okay things that I like it turns out
America is filled with wonderful
wonderful people and for all the hatred
that we tend to show each other on a
daily basis particularly on social media
which is bleeding over into real life
the fact is that when called upon the
American people are can be wonderful to
each other amazing example so there was
an El Paso shooting victim who was a
widower with no other family and there
was an open invite to people to come to
the funeral and they were afraid that
nobody would show up my friends were
afraid that nobody would show up instead
hundreds of people showed up hundreds of
Ranger showed up for the for the victims
funeral there's still a lot of
good-hearted compassionate people in the
United States lest we forget
Tony Vasco lost and you said love of his
life Marge it ended married 22 years she
was one of the 22 people killed at the
Walmart he has no other family in the
world and all of a sudden we see a total
inside and outside of this church of at
least 850 people and I just want to give
you a look at this line how far it
spreads and keep in mind right now on El
Paso it is 99 degrees outside and this
is the line here people waiting here
with the fans and most of them are from
the El Paso area and also nearby New
Mexico but I've talked to people also
from California from Arizona and from
you talking minutes amazing people
driving in from surrounding states to be
part of a funeral that that they don't
know the person it's amazing stuff
America is still a great country and
becoming better in its tolerance
becoming better in its in its
willingness to overlook differences and
its acceptance of people who are
different that's a wonderful wonderful
thing and divisive attempts to tear
Americans apart whether it's coming from
the right left or Center are bad and
this is is evidence I mean people are
looking to be out there for each other
and they should be okay time for a quick
thing that I hate so clashes broke out
in Portland over the weekend because it
was a weekend in Portland and there were
some dueling rallies won by the proud
boys and won by an Tifa we've seen these
sorts of things break out routinely
naturally the media covered this as
though were fascists and anti-fascist
doesn't matter then antigua has gotten
extraordinarily violent with people in
the past including in portland they beat
up my friend and you know democrats
still will not denounce Antipa they're
going to go along with this this bizarre
notion that an Tifa actually is
anti-fascist and not just a bunch of
thugs and masks running around beating
people up here is a list of Democrats
who are respond how they responded to
TPU essays Bennie Johnson when he asked
them to denounce an TFI her senator
Kirsten Gillibrand for example I was
wondering if you could take this
opportunity to denounce and Tifa
as a group would you be willing so
publicly there TT for today
what do you that's really in Castro no
no do be willing to denounce antifa
publicly right now marianne williamson
okay and it just goes on and on and on
and on the only person who would even
come close to doing it was Joe Biden who
said that he denounces hate on all sides
and that at least is that that at least
is closer to the answer okay but the
fact that the Democrats that people on
the left continue to cover for an tyfa
is pretty telling about what they want
from American politics antiva are really
bad folks really really bad people they
are people who have threatened my life
the lives of people that I know the fact
that you cannot get a willingness to
denounce just the same way that on the
right you should have a willingness to
denounce white supremacist and people
get violent this is this is it's getting
ugly so the flip side of people
gathering together to try and to try and
band together against the forces of
darkness is people who will not do so
apparently including leading Democratic
politicians all righty we'll be back
here later today with two additional
hours of content I'm Ben Shapiro this is
the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Robert Sterling directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring senior
producer Jonathan hey our supervising
producer is Mathis Glover and our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
edited by Adam Stevens audio is mixed by
Mike Cora Mena hair and makeup is by
Jesuit alvera production assistant Nick
Sheehan the Ben Shapiro show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
hey everyone its Andrew Clavin host of
the Andrew Clavin show the New York
Medical Examiner has declared the death
of the New York Times a suicide after
the wealthy but perverted former
newspaper strangled itself in a
philosophical Cell of its own making
will get to the heart of the conspiracy
in the Andrew Clavin show I am Andrew
clay